look who's here in studio uh one of our
favorites uh not just as a guest but
also sitting in this chair uh when i
cannot and good to see you ryan leaf how
are you sir i'm doing well rich good to
see you good to see you and congrats on
the dropping i guess as the kids say of
your new podcast uh on the action park
network uh kevin connolly of uh
entourage fame starting his own podcast
network uh he's not starting he's up and
running and uh bust is the name of the
podcast about your it's the ryan leaf
story and there you are number 16 from
way back in the day is the san diego
charger so i'll just jump in right uh
you know you and i have spoken about
this off the air like so why
why bust why just go out and just say
bust is the name of your story ryan i
just think it uh
well i think it sells better i just do
because people associate that word with
me um and i also thought and kevin and i
discussed this you know he always says
to me right he's like ryan if you're a
bust what the hell is everybody else you
know what's the worst word for robust in
that scenario and i just said
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna roll with it
i'm gonna take the power away from that
word i don't let it affect me in a
negative way anymore i used to i mean it
used to bother me a ton
and i just i i just don't and if anybody
ever has a chance
to say anything again i always go well
that's the name of my podcast yes so i
understand there you go okay so that's
now a new answer for you yeah okay very
good so uh how many episodes what are we
gonna what are we learning what are you
uh have you have you all right i won't
pepper you with questions but how many
episodes in this pod right now i think
we're gonna be at ten
okay possibly twelve uh so you haven't
you haven't recorded them all we've
recorded pretty much
we've done nine of them so we're at the
back end of everything and i just was
talking to him the other day about us
like i don't know if we can
fit in like
the redemptive part of this in one
episode like right sure you know i feel
like it's going to need a little more
because ultimately
the reason i'm doing this and why we've
chose to do this is that there are
people out there that are continuing to
struggle or feel like they are all alone
in all of this and they'll hear
something that they can relate to and
know that there's a solution
because why would i keep trying to rip
the band-aid off over and over and over
again to do this it's about other people
it could never be about me again when
i'm when i'm doing something like this
okay so who are the guests like what are
you talking about nobody you're just
talking it is my straight testimonial so
if anybody has come and seen me speak
over the years right
uh it that's usually about an hour
format 50 minutes to an hour i bet you
kevin and i have spent
18 hours in the recording booth so now
kevin is what he's just he's producing
you yeah like straight up producing him
anna my my wife to be uh is produced it
with our production company as well as
as kevin kevin was in the sessions with
me
um
i just flat out got in front of the
microphone and started telling my story
from when i was born until where i'm at
right now and he if he had some
questions or if he needed something
reaffirmed or something like that he
he'd pop in a questionnaire here there
so him and i
um we've developed a really really good
relationship and uh we really feel like
this can help people and so when he
jumped on board i was like okay i'm
willing to do this i trust him okay
that's the biggest thing interesting
because you know um
[Music]
i'm just wondering if you had
interviewed somebody from your past who
had a front row seat to what was going
on
with you who would you have chosen
well who had you chosen probably jay
posner would probably be one of them and
he is he's the reporter for the san
diego union tribune that that i uh went
viral with where i was yelling at him
uh the reporter
what did he ask you that day
it probably didn't matter what he asked
me i think it was something he wrote the
day before about what went on in the
locker room and then i was
so humiliated and embarrassed about how
i performed
or how i played the worst football game
you can imagine um wasn't used to doing
that
uh didn't like the criticism
uh he reported something that was
private in the locker room after that
kansas city game and i
after our little
gaggle of
or press conference in the locker room
on monday i asked him to stick around
and and uh
and tried to be the intimidating big
tough football player
and tell him how it was like you were a
peon i am the star
uh you're gonna do what i tell you to do
or we're not gonna have a relationship
moving forward and he knew that he kind
of had me and baited me a little bit and
then there was a camera in the corner of
the locker room panned around of course
and caught that
and it became kind of a caricature of
who i who i was i didn't yell at any
more reporters after that but still to
this day like
you know
ryan lee feels the reporters that's just
what it is and the internet had just
started and it became one of the first
viral videos that existed so like when
jim everts talked about they talk about
the jim rohm interview right
when they talk about me they talk about
the the blow up with the reporter so i
get it so he probably would have been a
good i've interviewed him before on a
san diego uh radio station we've made
you know we've made our i've made my
amends with him
um i think my best best uh point was
that i could have handled that better
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah so if you could go back in time
obviously this podcast wouldn't exist
right but if you could go back in time
you know what would you have told your
younger self i would have just you know
i wouldn't have changed anything i would
have treated people better i think even
even being a poor football player and
everything that went down and how just
how you treat people i just thought i
was so much more important than
everybody else rich because i could play
this silly game like that made me a
better human being than than you
and uh i had to be humbled i had to be
humbled in a way where i woke up on a
prison cell floor
and i continue to be humbled still
because there will be moments where i
think okay i've got this figured out i'm
at this place right we're going to knock
you back down because that's just that's
just how life is and it's not fair it's
how you deal with it that matters and
this is how i'm dealing with it and it's
a daily daily thing no matter what and
i love it
what do you mean you love it i just love
my life
and what it's become sure because of
everything that has transpired and the
struggles i still go through because i
know like i know where my feet are every
single day
and i and i i'm grounded in that like
today is today tomorrow i have no idea
maybe i'll get thrown back in prison
tomorrow i have no idea but if i do
today what i did yesterday
most likely i'll lay my head down feel
of peace and go about my business the
next day too ryan leaf here on the rich
eisen show in person bust is his new
podcast out
of the action park media
label that's kevin connolly's label and
he's producing you and so is anna was
producing you as well and you're here on
this show right now so um nature versus
nurture we hear that so much when it
comes obviously to quarterbacks in the
nfl and the situations that they're put
in and clearly there's more than just
football at work as to what had happened
to you and where you are today but do
you think that
there were football things that if they
were different different team different
city different scenarios that you
weren't attached to the hip to peyton
manning being drafted in or
if you weren't thrown right in and have
that sort of expectation level placed
upon you that things would have been
different do you think at all i'd like
to think so but then again i know who i
am and
geography doesn't change who you are
like i was the problem like it may have
been covered my like my character
defects may have been more
masked if i had marshall falk running
the ball and marvin harrison to throw to
but ultimately
if i would have led the league in
interceptions like payton did my his
rookie year i don't know how i would
have handled that i would have seen that
as a terrible failure
and of course i dealt with failure so
poorly so i think ultimately no matter
where i went
there i am
and that's the issue so i always have to
keep that in mind
um you know they asked me the question a
lot like if i had the same kind of
mindset now that i did back then would
it be different yeah well of course it
would be different because i would have
thought of things much differently my
talent was
second to none that's why the moniker
bust exists you have to be extremely
talented to be considered that like they
don't talk about a guy who's drafted in
the seventh round and plays for three
years and and really doesn't play right
that's just not the same conversation
that exists so you have to be extremely
talented and then when you don't live up
to those expectations
people
for whatever reason i guess find a
little joy in the fact that that that
name can be associated to it so it's
by doing the podcast it's simply my
testimony from the beginning to the end
and we're hoping to kind of take away
really and redefine what the word bust
means
um and that's where season twos and
threes and fours go into come in where
now i've set this precedent like i can
take this to somebody who struggled or
is continuing to struggle and say hey
here's a platform for you to do the same
thing to tell your story
to be therapeutic in a way for you and
maybe to educate others and kind of
explain what you went on and now there's
a platform for that you may not like the
name and that may dissuade you from
doing something like that but i think
there's a lot of people in many genres
of sports that i'd love to talk to in
years to come about those things guys
that were supposed to live up to such
high expectations didn't how they dealt
with it are they in a positive and
negative space right now i think it'd be
extremely interesting what would have
been the reaction
after
you know you
began to struggle in that public
moment in the blow up in the locker room
with the reporter you mentioned his name
jay posner what would have happened if
back then you had put out a statement i
need to step away from the game to work
on my mental health
similar to what calvin ridley just did
what would the reaction have been
that would have been crucified probably
right 1998 they would have looked at me
like i was nuts
um
it was let's put it this way rich and i
think i've talked to you about this
there's never been a trailblazer for any
of this right so when i was
deciding on whether or not i should
continue to play i was in seattle mike
holmgren was the head coach
and instead of walking into his office
and going
mike i'm i don't know what's wrong
i can't get out of bed i feel sad all
the time i feel lazy uh i don't know
what to do can you help me
there's been no one in my lifetime
growing up in montana with the cowboy
culture and in the locker rooms i've
never seen another man actually do that
so how was i supposed to know to do
something like that in that moment like
the the moment was too overwhelming for
me as a 21 year old trying to lead a
bunch of men
it would have not been accepted and it
would never have crossed my mind
to even say something like that because
that that wasn't a that wasn't a
solution that i could use
i never even thought about that what a
what a what a thing to stand up in front
of the cameras that next day when i was
reading off an apology my dad helped me
write that i just tossed into a locker
because i didn't want to read the
apology and say i'm really struggling
with my mental health here the moment
has gotten too big for me i want to do
this i want to do this well and i need
to step away and make sure i'm doing it
the right way
wow
boom that blows my mind right now when
you say yeah because you're a great
interviewer oh
you know
please no i i love talking to you about
this stuff because it is so damn
important
it's so important you know and what
you're talking about and what glaze jay
glazer talks about and i know you're
you're you're active with merging vets
and players and how thursday night i'm
going to do the the workout in
dallas at 18 t stadium with all the
community and vets because i'm calling
the tcu game this weekend so so you're
going to go do that which is where
everybody can get together and you work
out so you work your body and then you
work your mind and you work your heart
all in one night where you work out
together you get the sweat going and
then you sit around you talk my wife and
i have been privy to these um
conversations and these gatherings and
so it is important and it's it's it's
just pretty
what's the word for it other than cool
that that we're seeing calvin ridley
can step away
right and there aren't people and if
they are it's like to hell with you you
know hey they could have used him this
week in dallas and you're not hearing
any of his teammates saying that we had
his coach arthur smith on this past week
and he's like
when i asked him like so you're going to
check back in with him to see what's
going on he's like i want to talk about
that
and we're just treating it like you know
i i'm not going to sit here and just say
we're putting a time frame on it right
you know this doesn't have a crutch it
doesn't have a cast it doesn't have
anything like that so i'm just wondering
like if that outlet was in fact
available to you in 1998 you probably
wouldn't even have taken it you think
because of the way that it was looked at
at the time or yeah i mean i there was
no there was no like i said a trail
there was nobody i would have been like
the first to do that
in that moment and they would have been
like what a terrible mistake we made we
drafted this guy that was completely
incapable
of functioning you know and one of the
biggest
uh
comments about me is i i was so talented
but i didn't i didn't have the the
acumen i didn't have what was between
the ears right
there was a local kid from my high
school who was an amazing quarterback he
was this guy i looked up to he was the
state champion and he would go on to
greatness at the university of montana
and uh they always would they always
would tell me that if i had uh his name
was dave dickinson if i would have dave
dickinson's mind i would have been a pro
football hall of famer and there may be
some truth to that he was one of the
smartest people because he was
completely undersized won the walter
payton award won a national championship
at the university of montana played in
the cfl won grey cups he's now coaching
up there
he's one of my heroes growing up so
there may be some truth in that
but i also think you can tell from the
fact when i host your show and who i am
now like
my brain works just fine
uh it's a matter how i chose to use it
at the time i chose to believe
and think that i was just
above everybody else so i couldn't show
any weakness okay so we are now um 10
weeks into the nfl season
ryan leaf the best team in the nfl
is
i have no idea do you have any idea well
correct answer yeah that's the correct
answer i would tell you right now who i
think is probably playing the best and
who
is going to move forward and do some
good things let me guys let me guess let
me guess the team that's playing the
best football right now
and is going to move forward
to me
is new england that's my answer for you
i think it's the patriots i mean they
are playing that incredible incredible
football
what belichick and has done on the
defensive side of the football put aside
what mack jones has done in his
development right i mean early on the
season there were some mistakes that
that cost them games that first game
against miami if they don't fumble the
football you know right there they're in
a great position so yeah i think they're
playing the best now
green bay is the other team that's out
there that you like if aaron rodgers
plays a week ago they they most likely
beat kansas i would agree with that uh
so their only loss would be just this
inconspicuous are uh um
in descriptive first game of the season
against the saints right so
right now i would say
the patriots are playing the best green
bay the loss of aaron jones could be
something but a.j dylan really stepped
up on saturday or on sunday
um and then tennessee they just keep
figuring it out but i don't have a lot
of like faith in it i mean a two-point
win against the saints against a backup
quarterback on sunday well here's the
thing about the titans in uh mr hoskins
if you can put their schedule up i don't
see where how many more losses they've
got in front of them yeah they've got
both games against houston texas
remaining starting with this week
they have the game i think that's going
to tell a lot new england they got to go
to foxborough by the way that
thanksgiving sunday week 12 weekend is
insane because it's when the rams come
off of the buy and take on the packers
you've got this game
as well i'm sure there's many others
there's another game against
jacksonville
their their their home against miami
then you've got a visit to pittsburgh uh
an early
thursday game obviously at the kickoff
uh um christmas week
home against san francisco which may
have just woken up a bit
i don't know man i mean that that looks
to me like a 14-3 13-4 finish that's
definitely gonna be your one seed unless
new england keeps winning and one of the
losses is to new england right i mean
that's you
i know we're we're overlooking rookie
quarterback all that sort of thing but
they are playing lights out over the
last night incredibly better they're
getting better yeah
and that's that's usually what bill
belichick does his teams get better
throughout the year you remember a few
years ago when they went to kansas city
with tom brady it was just it was over
moving on to cincinnati it was over yeah
and they just continue to get better i
mean he he compartmentalizes so well
week to week it just does it doesn't
matter what happened last week or what's
going to happen two weeks from now this
is what's in front of me and guess what
i saw something on film this is what
bill belichick's thing i saw something
on film this week that gives us a solid
advantage in this football game and i
know therefore we're going to dominate
it doesn't matter who the opponent is
and this year more than any other year
that seems to be the case every single
week i i called the titans uh rams game
two weeks ago yeah here in sofi and i
was just blown away with how
buyered and that defense knew what they
needed to do against matthew sefer they
saw something they heard something on
film because
the interception that bayern made
matthew stafford's checking to something
there he's checking to that out route
and buyer can see it and you can see him
as he starts to walk down and move out
to that flat before the pass is even
snapped or the ball is even snapped sure
enough he flies right in front of
matthew stafford for the pick six that
game changed at that moment because
offensively tennessee's not doing
anything out of the ordinary what
they're doing is they're staying
committed to the run regardless of how
many yards they're getting out of it
they're just running the football to
stay balanced and that's keeping other
teams on their toes i mean that
tennessee visit to new england man
because as we all know that's the match
up and the spot where the brady era came
to the end and where vrabel's starting
to use the pla the uh
the rule book
against belichick in the same way that
belichick had previously used against
the jets
he's kind of got their number right
christopher kind of does actually no
derek henry though
no derek henry for this game i don't
know if that's gonna
i don't know if this is gonna matter i
don't i don't trust them let's just put
it that way i don't trust maybe that's
the only reason why it does it does
matter is because you you don't you
can't rely on that game
changing talented player especially in
the playoffs he is gone especially in
the playoffs when it is about limited
possessions
it's about running the football and
being physical
that's a huge difference
but it's all about schemes sometimes
leverage numbers and scheme and the best
in the business is bill belichick but
who but who who taught mike rabel
everything he knows
you assume he watched it right there
so uh ryan leaf here uh in studio let's
we want to talk about leverage numbers
scheme right how about scheme
you can't
you can't say you're better than kansas
city when you're scheming right no okay
you could say you're as good but i don't
think you're i don't think anybody's
better than them
and we saw
in my estimation as we've been saying
here last two days week 10 is the the
i'm back weekend dak and the cowboys
came back from that one awful loss to
denver cam literally said the words i'm
back twice okay and so
you look at the chiefs that looked like
the same with the niners for the first
time all year that's the niners team
running 40 times
opportunistic defense jimmy g making the
the throws but not the mistake like
that's
you know debo running downhill slashing
from different positions either catching
it or running it the chiefs screen game
defense coming up with big plays tyreek
hill open mahomes not making the mistake
five touchdowns 400 yards how how about
the chiefs do you think now ryan yeah
they looked every bit the part right
that they've been the last three years i
will say this though
in those weeks leading up to it where
everybody was questioning the kansas
city chiefs the ball wasn't bouncing
their way he'd make some of those crazy
throws like the left-handed throw that
was a completion in sunday night those
went the other way the previous weeks
correct on sunday night against las
vegas he made similar throws but this
time his play makers made the play how
about the high point to damien williams
he's running to his right throwing back
across the grain both numbers and hashes
to the end zone from
that would have been picked off in like
the first two months of the season well
they have been the ball's bounced a
different way you know and when you look
back in the past seasons with patrick
mahomes you were in awe of what he was
doing and then everybody jumped off that
that that bandwagon pretty quick this
year when those turned into turnovers
and you were like oh he's making making
foolish mistakes well this is exactly
what he's been doing he's just had the
skill position players to make the plays
and that's what happened on sunday night
so
you know if i'm looking at the afc west
there's not a team in that division that
i go
besides the chiefs right now that i that
i actually trust when it gets down to to
crunch time so
they are going to be in this
conversation um the chargers
inexplicably keep losing games that
you're like why
it seems to me that their big
game passing game has disappeared
now i don't know if it's mike williams
getting hurt but i also saw like a
target
sheet like the number of like where
where where the ball was going where are
the balls going justin herman everything
was like within 10 yards of the line of
scrimmage and it's kind of like he's got
the big arm he's got the legs too like
where
where has that game been the last minute
i think what people saw other than the
game in philly he had a great game in
philly but i think what the people saw
or
in particular defensive coordinators is
that
dude gets it when they blitz i mean flat
out can make explosive huge plays when
you blitz
and i don't think a lot of people
thought he was capable of doing that
coming out of college and when he
showcased that you're getting a lot of
zone defense now a big umbrella making
him take things underneath and mike
williams hasn't been the explosive guy
that they need to be keenan allen is a
real
really good wide receiver a possession
receiver a guy that can make catches
everywhere but
coaches have really limited
justin herbert and what he does down the
field because he was held under 200
yards passing
against minnesota mike zimmer's still a
genius when it comes to defensive
preparation
no matter how poorly the team plays down
the stretch or loose close games guy can
coach up a defense and
and they just made justin herbert look
like like normal on sunday well
we're talking about
teams that you can trust in the afc what
about the nfc the most trusted team and
know that the guy who's over your right
shoulder is a cowboy fan who's just been
really uh waiting to
jump into this subject matter um
last two days
in my man t.j jefferson over there
you can't trust
your team tj right
but you love them
why can't you trust the dallas cowboys i
think mike mccarthy
i really do ouch i really think that
that that it's going to come down to a
time management situation late in the
game that he has looked
incredibly poor at
hopefully the players overcome and
kellen moore is is continues to to roll
but they got the coordinators right yep
okay they stuck with kellen moore and
now look at him right they got rid of
mike nolan put in dan quinn they got the
coordinators right they've got the
personnel right they got the draft right
micah parsons is phenomenal so good okay
so good yeah travon digs it's been a
couple of weeks since he picked six
somebody but that just the fact that
next already this year yeah the fact
that i've already said that i've said
that just shows you how terrific he's
been their depth they've they've they've
won games they've won games
that
would have knocked them out of
contention or down a peg previous
despises mike mccarthy's no tyrant no
tyron smith no quarterback no pass
rushers like tank lawrence and randy
gregory am missing anything tj am i
missing anything right now i mean we had
gallup out for a while that's right
gallup gallup gallop
and they keep on like again if we're
going to sit here and for brockman's
sake say well damien harris fumbled
against the the dolphins and if nick
folk didn't you know boot that one off
of the upright against tom brady
if nuts and candies and butts and all
that about the patriots if fifths were
fist we'd all be drunk i guess that's
another way to put it another one there
you go um so
dallas
if they had you know just gotten that
extra oomph against tampa that one maybe
extra possession
then we're just talking about truly
burying the film against the denver
broncos and the cowboys are the most
trusted team well i wouldn't i'd say
green bay is the most trusted team and
why is that simply because of aaron
rodgers um the track record with coach
lefleur
just i mean they've lost what he's lost
eight games in his first three seasons
so far so far yes so i i trust them more
um and the fact that they if they can
get the one seed and make everybody come
through lambo this time with a real home
field advantage remember last year when
the nfc championship it was a limited
fan base it wasn't it would have been
the first time they got to host an nfc
championship it wasn't loud it wasn't
raucous the weather wasn't incredibly
poor
if dallas has to go
to green bay for an nfc championship i
find
that to be really difficult and i trust
green bay more than i trust dallas
that's not to say that i don't think
dallas can be that contender
they've won despite of mike mccarthy's
mistakes early on in the season yes and
they may be able to overcome that so
i don't trust him as much t.j but your
team has a real shot this year i think
so i don't know if that means anything
coming from me but there you go no it
means a lot i mean
you just went higher register though you
know
your team's got a real shot this year
i might have to cancel my leaf cowboys
jersey that i ordered you know but you
know i'll let that why did you order one
i'll just i'll give you one of mine
buddy
with it let's go i don't know if it's
game warren
somewhere mom and dad have in their
closet
somewhere go call it montana you can
find it you know who to give it to you
all right so um before uh i send you off
onto your good tuesday sir uh if you can
do something for me yeah i'd like to
rely on your college football acumen and
knowledge and expertise and i'd like you
to give me the scenario in which two
saturdays from now
i am bouncing off the walls walking on
air because michigan has just beaten
ohio state is there a scenario paint it
for me how that is possible
in 2021 ryan leaf this team's different
this team just has a physical nature
that hasn't existed in terms of how they
run the football
with jim harbaugh's teams in the past
and what they did against wisconsin
and what they did last weekend in happy
valley to
really
that's a game that they normally
wouldn't have won
it was close it was tied they ran a
great play call where they ran a pick
and made the penn state players run into
each other and it turned into a huge
touchdown that ultimately won them the
game correct those things
in the jim harbaugh era haven't been
consistent
he always lost big games especially on
the road hasn't happened this year but
the problem with that and i'm just going
to push back because i'm still looking
for the silver lining you're looking for
the silver bullet well it's just that
michigan was so inefficient throughout
the first three quarters and either
making mistakes or not getting it in the
end zone um and certainly against
wisconsin it was just a different team
those teams are not ohio state where
literally it appears every person who
catches the ball is not only wide open
by five yards but they're gonna be a top
five pick in the nfl draft like and so
that's been the problem is that when
michigan is inefficient on offense
against wisconsin or penn state or has
to settle for a field goal instead of
scoring a touchdown
they're down by three scores against
ohio state and things get out of hand
how how how how can michigan
like do they
match up well against ohio state's
defense in your estimation i don't what
you know i don't want to just you know
crash your dreams here it's okay okay no
i did ask for the scenario right
you would ask for the scenario and
that's what i was trying to give you
well i don't know how plausible that
scenario it's not very possible i'm
sorry all right
is a juggernaut on offense you're
exactly right now
cj stroud is still young yes still
hasn't a ton of experience he's been
very good
but there's been some defenses nebraska
in particular oregon for sure that found
ways to
limit him well michigan's got two guys
on the edge i know they put their hair
on hutchinson is a baller he reminds me
a ton of joey bosa
he really does he comes off that edge so
if he can become
that type of player in that type of game
why not why not us michigan
why not
all right
at least you're living in the good life
i
my state of college football has neither
one of their head coaches neither one of
it's going to be an interim i'm calling
the apple cup next week with two injured
head coaches in it so
how many interim head coach is going to
cut a single conference have
what we have right now three
who's going to be usc's next guy they're
already talking
bruce feldman our friend from fox is
talking about baylor's hd oh i've
covered baylor twice this year i've
spent a lot of time with dave miranda
he's not going anywhere
that dude and his family love waco okay
the people around there uh the team he's
put together okay i don't believe dave
around is going anywhere so who's usc
going to get do you think i have a
theory around college football and name
me a big city team
in college that is
that is just baller in a year and you're
out
they're just they don't exist anymore
for whatever reason it's about rural
communities that just get after their
football programs tuscaloosa athens
those places where they're tight-knit
communities for whatever reason it's
just the players are not lost in the
shuffle i find it very difficult to make
la a contender in college football again
i really do why i just think usc is
going to have a real problem with that
i've never heard that one before so
because why because there's many
different distractions distractions the
fan base it doesn't exist as much um i
usc has this brand this this sustaining
brand that i think could get them
through it i really do right but i think
it's gonna be a struggle
put that as a poll ask that question on
your show like
what big city team is just balling year
in and year out i think i mean notre
dame is not considered chicago even
though chicago considers notre dame
chicago right um
obviously new york city doesn't have one
miami but they're but miami's and they
haven't been good i mean miami is in the
absolute toilet right now yeah they're
i mean there is it's a weird theory but
i was talking about it with some of my
buddies last weekend and going you know
because the washington job just came
open and i'm like columbus seattle
columbus is not a huge like columbus
like austin and houston they're not i
mean houston is texas texas is oh texas
is gross
i'm gross i like that it's gross i
picked them to go seven and five they're
gonna go six and six or maybe
i got kansas this week too the the
hottest team in college football by the
way hottest team in colle hey man they
gave oklahoma a scare and then they took
texas right out how cool was that ending
right
oh my gosh yeah and i saw the video of
the parents um
you know the kid who caught the
two-point conversion uh never played
offensive never played an offensive snap
it's unbelievable the tight end yeah
never played a snap of offensive
football he's a walk-on and he caught
the winning two-point conversion to beat
texas and the parents are shooting the
video and the opposite end of the video
i'm getting goosebumps here were they in
the last row
it looked like the loves
still have the worst
in the history of football rooting on
somebody who they're you know
who they have as family um yeah it's
incredible stuff all right you know
there's a theory on that though put the
loves up there they don't have to hear
bad stuff being talked about if you're
down in the mix like you don't have to
hear anything from the fans you'd rather
you'd rather your family be all the way
up there oh i put my parents in the
nosebleeds every time we were on the
road no kidding yeah and then i told mom
to put the radio broadcast on the home
radio broadcast on in her ears so she
didn't have to listen to it that could
be one of the final episodes of season
one of boston everybody uh thanks for
coming in here ron really appreciate it
everybody check out bust
is where podcasts can all be acquired
the ryan leaf story season one of
hopefully as many seasons as you'd like
oh and by the way before we go you're
heading to london now you're going to be
a correspond what do you do you're i'm
going to be the nfl analyst uh in in
london for sky sports nfl and then this
year they we come here for the super
bowl so i'll be able to work through
that process too that's gonna be a lot
of fun you know you're a presenter
apparently that's what they call is
you're gonna be a presenter that's what
they call on-air uh personality really
well that's a host i don't know if what
they call an analyst i think i don't
know you keep telling me i'm an analyst
so okay we're gonna go with that have
you seen roy kent's behavior on that
role on uh ted lasso i think i've got
that's the bar i think i could yeah i
think i could be a good role can't yeah
i do
you should go and just do the whole
royalty people gonna be staying in
richmond actually so very good
fantastic well hit the beliefs on on
your way out hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here